tindy see there's a live picture of the
museum right now newly open spending the
works for several years that is now open
for business and our colleague Peter
Selene will take over from here and
about a hundred thousand visitors have
already toured the International Spy
Museum it's located in downtown
Washington about a block from the FBI
building and it's a contemporary it's a
look at the historical and contemporary
world of espionage and joining us here
to tell us about the museum is Peter
earnest who is the executive director
good morning mr. earnest good morning
Peter why a spy museum well why not
you've got museums on everything else I
heard about a museum one morning today
it was time I think it was time we've
gone through a very long period of a
Cold War occupying nearly half a century
and with the end of the Cold War you had
a lot of information available artifacts
available people available and the
amount of information intelligence if
you will about that period is of intense
interest to people and so we felt it was
time let's look at the Cold War let's
look back at the whole history of
espionage and the role that's played in
the history of our nation as well as
other nations well who were some of the
earliest spies some of the earliest
spies go back as far as recorded time I
think man has always wanted to know
what's going on in his neighbor's yard
so we could that's an assumption but
certainly since recorded time you can go
back as some people go back as early as
the Bible when Moses sent the men into
Canaan and but you can go back earlier
than that certainly the Trojan horse of
which we have a model here at the museum
but the arts of deception of strategical
intelligence and so forth go back as
certainly as earlier the writings of
sunsoo who was a Chinese military
strategist probably writing about 25 to
3,000 years ago
2,500 to 3,000 years ago what are some
of the exhibits that you have here
well the exhibits make an attempt to
bring the visitor to bring you all the
way from that period of sunsoo of the
the emergence of the ninjas in history
for example who were really spies there
were early forms of scouts up through
history through the Renaissance period
medieval Elizabeth the first court and
all the espionage that was practiced
there all the way up through the world
wars and up to contemporary times
including
and even going into the Gulf War it
talked about the Cold War period a
little bit was that the apex of spying I
wouldn't say it was the apex certainly
you had the beginnings of of of huge
spying on its citizens by the early
Soviet Union that Georgian ski in other
words the founder of the Abu the check
of the that what became what we known as
no is the KGB but the Cold War was very
much an intelligence war lots of things
went on that people did not know about
and I think that was the vacuum that was
filled by popular culture the world of
liquor a the world of James Bond those
worlds the television programs Maxwell
Smart
I spy Mission Impossible all of those
and that gave you a popular image or
popular culture model if you will of
espionage what you're seeing now is in
this museum is the reality of espionage
what were some of the things that we're
really used and in fact are still being
used by agents all over the world to
conduct particularly espionage which is
the world of spying we do cover
deception collection and so forth here
but we're very much about spies the
stories of spies and what about
technology technology we certain cover I
certainly cover if you go back into a
little room not far away from where
we're sitting there's a little case with
a pigeon in it and the pigeon has little
camera hanging on a little harness and
those pigeons were used in World War one
to fly over battlefields or towns of
interests the tent the camera had a
time-release shutter and so you had
continuous coverage of those areas that
was the beginnings along with balloons
of aerial surveillance where his
technology taken us all the way to the
geosynchronous satellites in orbit today
but the beginnings of that technology
were balloons and pigeons
I want to let our viewers know that we
will be touring the the museum
throughout the show mr. Ernests will be
back with us at nine o'clock to talk
about and take your calls about the
museum and we'll be taking some more
more shots of the museum what is your
background my background is CIA I spent
about thirty six years in CIA a little
over 20 of that was in the clandestine
service that is working with agents
recruiting agents and engaged in other
forms of
intelligence that is counterespionage
counterintelligence as well as covert
action
how would you recruit an agent very
carefully that's the only answer I'm
going to get on that question I don't
know if we have time to go into the
whole process well we'll have time at 9
o'clock so we'll find out about that at
9 o'clock but joining us now is bill
Gertz he is the author of this book
breakdown how America's intelligence
failures led to September 11th and he
joins us at our setback in Capitol Hill
good morning mr. Gert's good morning I
want to ask you about a quote or a line
here in your book you talked about the
CIA and this is what you write you write
that the most important problem facing
US intelligence agencies today is the
lack of accountability what did you mean
by that well I think that there has been
a real problem with holding people
accountable for what they have done or
not done as it as it relates to the case
of September 11th I'm fairly critical of
the intelligence community I think it's
not structured to deal with terrorism
there are huge gaps between domestic
intelligence and foreign intelligence
and that was really the problem as it
relates to the conspiracy that led to
September 11th walk us through the
breakdown as you as you see it well you
can look at it and much has been said
and written recently about the failure
to put the pieces together there was
information that a terrorist attack was
planned there were signs there was the
intercepts that were the day before but
those weren't put together what I looked
at was more of a structural problem the
US intelligence community was really
structured to go after foreign
governments and foreign militaries and
it was also very technology oriented
especially in in more recent years it
also there's an over reliance on foreign
liaison with foreign intelligence
services and not enough human spying to
me that was really the root failure was
the fact that we didn't have a good
human intelligence spying capability
that could get inside these terrorist
groups disrupt them and find out
their plans were we're gonna put the
numbers on the screen if you'd like to
talk to Bill Gertz about his new book
the numbers are on the screen two oh two
five eight five three eight eight zero
for Republicans 202 585 381 for
Democrats in 202 585 3 882 for all
others mr. Kurtz you also write about
the money we've been asking our viewers
this morning about intelligence funding
and what you write is that beginning in
1995 6.7 billion was added to government
agencies for counterterrorism by 2001 it
was up to nineteen point five billion
and after September 11th about thirty
seven point seven billion you say that
in the past this money was usually spent
on new computer systems analyst hardware
and in the FBI on Chevy Suburbans what
it did not do was prevent the September
11th terrorist attack where is the money
going now well it's going into the
bureaucracy and I'm very concerned about
intelligence spending there has been a
big boost the budget this year is
estimated to be somewhere in the range
of 35 billion dollars and my concern is
that if you're pouring money into a
system that's broken that it won't be
spent well and it won't be used well I'm
calling for some serious reform efforts
we really need to fix these problems
before we put money into a broken system
first call up for Bill Gertz is from
Baker City Oregon good morning
Baker City Oregon hello go ahead Oregon
you're on the air
hi thanks for Steve Smith I had a few
questions in comments one what does a
person have to do to make the
immigration FBI immigration watchlist
for two if you're on this list
why aren't you watched for three I don't
hear any mentioning about the
Afghanistan pipeline and that was a
major factor I think in what happened
here there's a lot of things that I have
questions about that most people don't I
call them sepal i guess you could figure
out why mr. Gertz well the the the
watchlist
there is something called the tip-off
which is a it's actually a State
Department and intelligence community
and law enforcement list I don't know
how they put the names on the list but I
do know that there are big problems
especially as it relates to Islamic
terrorists and suspected terrorists in
my research for this book I found that
there was resistance in the intelligence
community to even doing such something
that seemingly so simple as
standardizing the names there was a
resistance thus you have Osama's Ben
Laden's name spelled in some cases with
an O and some cases with a u so that's
that's one of the problems there as for
the Afghan pipeline I guess you're
referring to the system of training
terrorists I think that that was known
at least in the mid 90s and the the
first time anything was done really
seriously was the 1998 attacks on the
terrorist camps there that didn't really
seem to do much in the way of disrupting
the terrorists in my research for the
book I also found out that the the CIA
had very few agents inside Afghanistan
almost none at the time of September
11th and to me this seems to be a big
failing because clearly this was the
origin of the terrorists that carried
out the September 11th attacks Milbourne
Florida Republican good morning Hey how
much didn't you think the do you think
that the Torricelli bill back in the 90s
hurts our intelligence toward 9/11 if
that never went through do you think we
might have had a chance to stop 9/11 and
in reference to the first question they
had on spending less money or more money
it if Congress were to get rid of the
pork belly I mean if it was illegal for
you know to get rid all that stuff and
put Defense Intelligence first and
schooling in health care sucking
wouldn't that help a lot I think what
the callers
referring to our what I refer to as the
Deutsche rules and these were rules that
were imposed under pressure from Senator
Robert Torricelli back in the 90s and it
was based on some reporting that in
Guatemala the CIA was supposedly
involved with a government official who
violated the human rights of Americans
what the overall effect was was
extremely negative whether or not these
rules had they not been in place would
have led to stopping September 11th is
hard to say but what the rules did was
said that the CIA officers in the field
couldn't recruit agents who had unsavory
backgrounds and this would be like
asking the FBI not to use informants
inside the Mafia because they had
unsavory backgrounds this has been a
real problem now the CIA will tell you
that in there was never a case where
they returned down to recruitment but it
doesn't work that way it has a chilling
effect on the agents in the field and
there was a terrorism Commission in 2000
headed by L Paul Bremer which looked at
this question and interviewed a number
of field agents and to a man or woman
they said that this was an impediment to
the ability to go out and recruit agents
in the field the Congress then after
September 11th ordered the CIA to
rescind these rules and in in a sign of
how entrenched the bureaucracy is the
CIA modified those rules but they didn't
rescind them so they're still in place
and and to me it was it is a big problem
Bill Gertz is a defense and national
security correspondent for The
Washington Times he's also the author of
this book breakdown which is just brand
new our next call for him comes from
Chatham New Jersey good morning good
morning I just have one question that's
been bothering me since September the
11th when the second plane was going to
fly into the second tower the air
traffic controller said they sat there
for 11 minutes worried about the plane
hitting at the same time they were
telling the people to go back to their
desk why what kind of a mix
was that this was a real security
failure I mean there had never been
anything like that before I think that
was the main problem there had been no
training to how to deal with this so
clearly there there was an airline
security problem a controller problem we
also know that that when they sought
military help in scrambling Jets the
Jets that were deployed were too far
away to get there in time to have done
anything yeah I also in my book I
recount the story of Rick Rescorla who
is a real hero in in this issue he was
the security director for Morgan Stanley
Dean Witter inside the World Trade
Center and this guy was a really a
unique person he was originally a
British national became a US citizen
fought in Vietnam as a Special Forces
soldier and his job was security at the
Trade Center he did a survey in the
early 90s of the building and said hey
if terrorists are gonna blow this up
they're gonna drive a truck in to the
basement and try to weaken one of the
supports well that happened in 93 after
that and tried a week in one of the
supports well that happened in 93 after
that he had the vision to say that the
next threat could be an airliner that
would be flown into the building he
tried to get his company to move but
they had a lease that was wasn't up to
2006 so what he did was periodically
hold evacuation drills for 3,000 of the
employees and every few months with a
bullhorn he'd marched them down 70 to 50
stairs of the World Trade Center well on
that day he was ready to go got the
bullhorn the Port Authority told him
that he should stay in the building this
was the North Tower after the South
Tower had been hit he said sorry and he
used some other colorful language but
said no he evacuated 3,000 people saved
3,000 people's lives by good practice
the tragedy he went back in the building
to save one or two missing employees and
the building collapsed and he died but
again this is a
this is the kind of person you know Jim
Woolsey the former CIA director said
this is the kind of person you want at
the head of your Directorate of
operations your spying operations
because he had an intuition or a feel
for what terrorists were doing bill
Gertz why do you talk about in your book
about the USS Cole incident the Khobar
Towers incident and also the embassy
bombings in Africa
well this relates to Osama bin Laden in
my view not enough was done to recognize
the threat that this group that this
individual and the his group posed to
the United States in the early 90s bin
Laden began speaking out and ordering
his followers to kill Americans both
civilians and military personnel he
wanted to drive the United States
presence out of Saudi Arabia he also had
an affinity for the Palestinians in
Israel so this was an indication that
this was a problem but not only did he
actually talk about this and and order
his followers to do that a short time
after that we saw that his group started
blowing up Americans first there was the
Dharan bombing in Saudi Arabia which
killed a number of US soldiers then the
embassy bombings in Africa then the USS
Cole you know in the intelligence
business this is a 100% indicator that
you have a serious problem
and I don't think enough was done to
recognize the problem and realize that
this pose not just a low-intensity
conflict threat to the United States but
actually what happened in September 11th
was a strategic attack and a strategic
intelligence failure Yellow Springs Ohio
good morning hello I'm calling on behalf
of Yellow Springs and a lot of the local
people in America just wanted to know
why we would spend forty three billion
dollars on intelligence and not spend
that much money on scientific research
for other fuel modules to operate our
transportation devices well I guess you
could debate how federal money is spent
you know
that's not something that I I really do
but to me I think intelligence money if
it's spent on a good structure is really
really important because especially in
the war on terrorism
I think intelligence is the first line
of defense and and if we're going to win
the war on terrorism and stop terrorists
from killing thousands of Americans this
is the investment that we have to make
it's not just a question of investing
money for scientific research you know
it's always a balance between whether
you invest in scientific research or
national security I think in the current
context there there's a dire need to
spend money for national security bill
Gertz that caller said 43 billion is
being spent you use the figure 37
billion in your book where do those
figures come from well the the figures
for intelligence spending are classified
and they're usually put within the
defense and intelligence budgets the big
consumers of that budget are the high
tech agencies namely the National
Security Agency which conducts
electronic eavesdropping and the
National Reconnaissance Office which
builds and operates our spy satellites
these agencies rely heavily on the
contractor community there's a space
component to launching their satellites
that do this and conduct other
operations the rest of the money goes to
the CIA FBI National Security Division
and to the military services it's hard
to gauge it information comes from from
officials who have access to the secret
budget and it's not exactly because they
they want to keep secret what their
budget is st. Cloud Florida good morning
bill morning i bill Donkin so we're here
ran right out and bought your book and
I'm waiting for delivery from Amazon I
have a couple of questions Patrick
Moynihan was fighting the
declassification obfuscators in
Washington and I've been waiting to see
more in the Venona files on the web and
I feel as a delay
or some sort of assocation going on the
freedom of information on these issues
I'm interested in finding out who was
involved in what they do back in the 40s
and 50s okay well a lot of information
has been Declassified the Venona files
were the basically information on who
was spying they were Russian KGB decrypt
information which revealed the Russian
spy networks in the United States
there's been a number of excellent books
on that including one by her brahmer
Steen who's an expert on that field and
I would recommend you take a look at
that we're at the International Spy
Museum in downtown Washington DC will be
showing you shots of it throughout the
program this morning bill Gertz is back
at our studio on Capitol Hill and our
next call for him comes from Austin
Texas good morning morning mr. gertz are
just curious about your opinion on the
homeland security reorganization and
specifically why there's not some
reorganization going on for
counterintelligence domestically there
there are some very specific things that
I find out that here in Texas we're not
doing like comparing the absconder file
with fingerprints of taxi cab drivers
that are on file I get local
municipalities I'm just wondering why we
got to put the Coast Guard with the pest
control people and not figure out who
the IMS most wanted or yeah that's a
good good question the the
reorganization of the Homeland Security
Department really focuses on the
security agencies as opposed to the
intelligence agencies and by that I mean
that these security functions in in a
sense are gatekeepers they're really
trying to deal with the perimeter of
Defense Intelligence on the other hand
crosses both sides of the offense of the
fence which involves going out and
spying on people and in the case of
terrorists getting inside terrorists
organizations finding who their
supporters are stopping the money and so
forth domestically
I would point out that I'm very
skeptical about the new department in
particular it has excluded the
intelligence community so in a sense
it's going to be a consumer as opposed
to having the ability to go out and
collect intelligence that's a that's a
real shortcoming I think it's a
reflection of the resistance within the
intelligence community to real reform in
my book I make some suggestions for
reform including the creation of a new
clandestine service I think it's time to
recognize that the CIA's Directorate of
operations is not doing the job and it's
time to start over with new people
combining the defence ument service or
human intelligence service with the
Directorate of operations and creating a
new agency I think that that would go a
long way towards starting us on the road
to to real reform so that we can get
inside of these terrorist groups you
know I interviewed one FBI official who
told me that if we don't succeed in
stopping these terrorists we're going to
be fighting this war against terrorism
for a hundred years so I think we we
have a big task ahead of us Cleveland
good morning morning I guess my question
has been related to the to the media
with the nature of the the media as it
is to get the hottest story I mean how
do you balance intelligence and keeping
things black so to speak when the media
wants to you know jump on to the you
know the hottest thing out there and you
know willing to do whatever it takes to
do so good question
this is something that I can tell you
personally I grapple with all the time
as I'm sure that other reporters who
cover national security affairs deal
with it it's it's a tough call I'm in
the information business on my job is to
report the news and that's what I do and
we go after news stories wherever they
are you know there certainly are some
criticisms of the media for reporting
sensitive information I don't look at it
that way
I report the news
and if they're and in doing so we try to
be responsible I can be honest we're not
always responsible but I can tell you
that that we have on many occasions
withheld information at the request of
the government when they've made a case
that withholding that information could
save someone's life that's really the
bottom line for us again it's always a
tough call it's it's done with the the
help of experts my editors are the final
arbiters of actually what goes in the
newspaper but you know we live in the
most open society in the world we have
the freest press in the world and with
that comes a certain responsibility and
I think we've we've tried to to do that
you know in our in a proper way
Cape Cod you're on the air good morning
how reliable is intelligence information
given to us by Israel do we always take
it as face value also there is estimated
that there are American Jews living in
Israel between 60 and 80 thousand who
enjoy dual citizenship doesn't dual
citizenship almost automatically make
dual loyalty
well I'd I would disagree on the dual
citizenship and do a loyalty you know I
mean the we've had many Americans who
are also Israeli citizens but on the
issue of Israeli intelligence clearly
one of the problems and this this
highlights one of the problems in my
book breakdown is that there has been an
over reliance on what they call foreign
liaison intelligence in the case of
Israel of the United States has relied
heavily on information provided by
Israeli to intelligence and the way that
works is that our tremendous advantage
in intelligence gathering is our high
technology capability there it's just
unmatched in the world and clearly the
best intelligence that we get
certainly not for terrorists but in in a
strategic sense spying on foreign
nations comes from electronic
intelligence intercepts and photography
the weakest part of US intelligence as I
mentioned earlier is our human spying
capability which has severely eroded
over the last several decades to try and
improve that we've traded some of our
high-tech intelligence that could be
helpful to Israel and Israel for its
part provides us with some of the human
intelligence information that that they
gather and the same goes for other
nations around the world it's it they
try to do it in a collegial way they try
to do it in a way that's going to
protect their sources and there are also
national interests involved so the
problem with not having a unilateral
human intelligence capability is that
you may not get the information you need
and I highlight an example of that in my
book and talking about one Persian Gulf
nation that offered up some terrorists
to the United States and two FBI agents
actually flew into that nation they were
ready to pick up this terrorists and
before they could before the person
could be delivered it turned out that
someone in that government sent those
terrorists off to another place so that
they would escape us capture that's kind
of the example of the problems you have
with reliance on foreign liaison
mr. Gert's did you find that US
intelligence agencies had been able to
infiltrate Osama bin Laden's Network no
and in fact and especially in the United
States basically one of the documents
that I uncovered said that it was very
difficult to evaluate information about
people who had done penetrated bin
Laden's group because there was no way
to verify the information as it relates
to the FBI in late 2000 the FBI reported
to the White House that there were no
al-qaeda cells inside the United States
I think that this is a
reflection of the problems with FBI
intelligence-gathering they really did
not have a good domestic intelligence
capability the estimates are today that
as many as 5,000 al-qaeda may be in the
United States next call Yonkers New York
good morning yes I studied Persian in
70s and that was because the University
of Texas had like many other fine
universities the government of Iran led
by the shop poured millions and millions
and millions of dollars into education
which was good for me because I was
interested in it but it's an example of
how that one government among many
co-opted the judgment of many
responsible Americans in the media in
politics and I I know for personal fact
in intelligence and I'm curious now you
know we know that the FBI was richly
penetrated by Russian agents throughout
the 70s 80s and maybe even into the 90s
we know that the CIA was first I'm gonna
get your book as I found fascinating do
you go much into the Louis Freeh era and
how the current problems were either
ignored or just not dealt with properly
by him and and second what do you see
changing if anything the institutional
mindset that you know we're we're doing
the right thing all we need is new money
okay let me take the first one the the
Russian penetration of US intelligence
was a disaster and it had some
unintended bureaucratic consequences
first of all obviously we had someone
with complete access to our secrets and
you know I like to point out when when
oftentimes the CIA complains about leaks
to the media these are inconsequential
when you consider the extreme damage to
national security that was caused by
Aldrich Ames in the CIA
and Hanson in the FBI and the DIA the
Defense Intelligence Agency had its own
Cuban agent who operated for 10 years
this is a this is a serious problem
there was devastating for an
intelligence agency as
former or intelligence expert put it to
me it's almost better not to have any
intelligence at all than to have one
that's penetrated because of the damage
that it can cause they can feed you
false information they can operate on
the information that you think is secret
and the result of that has been an
intense increase in security which has
had a negative effect on the ability to
do offensive spying one CIA officer
explained to me that the security rules
in the wake of these spy cases have
become so draconian and again it's an
overreaction to those spy cases that it
has really hampered the ability to get
people cleared and to use foreign agents
because there's so much suspicion it's a
an overemphasis on security as it
relates to Louis Freeh I do highlight
that the period during the Clinton
administration in the FBI the problem
there was really in in the FBI as it
relates to intelligence they D
emphasized intelligence and in fact they
stopped calling themselves an
intelligence division they used the term
national security under Louis Freeh they
made several management changes and
moved officials around and it had a
really negative effect on the ability of
the national security specialists and if
you understand the FBI culture at all
there really is a two types there were
the counter spy types people whose job
it was to go after foreign spies and and
in terrorists and then there were the
criminal side guys and there was always
this tension between the two well under
Louis Freeh the whole focus was on the
criminal side and the intelligence side
was de-emphasized and that was really
unfortunate we're live at the
International Spy Museum and down in
downtown Washington DC and as we take
this next call we're going to show you a
bit of it Athens Georgia good morning
good morning mr. Kurtz I I've been
having a question since September 11th
happened and I've never seen anything
questioned about it or answered I
like to know how the government
identified the hijackers all 19 of them
as quickly as they did with all the
reports that are coming out on the
arrests of people that supplied false
identifications false passports to these
people were there are no other Muslims
on those planes were there no other
Arabs or Middle Easterners or how
exactly were they identified so quickly
it was it was a good piece of
investigative work I think that the bulk
of that was done through the passenger
manifest they were able to identify the
people on the planes who and their
activities and and trace those names
back to suspected al-qaeda people I
wanted to mention earlier on the the
previous caller about changing the the
cultural within the institution this is
really the most difficult problem you
have a very problematic culture within
the intelligence community and that's
going to be the hardest thing to change
my recommendation is that the President
himself is going to have to step in to
fix the problem because I don't think
the intelligence community is capable of
reforming itself and the Congress has
shown that it too is not really willing
to get into the difficult task of
reshaping intelligence for the war on
terrorism next call for build Gertz
comes from jacksonville florida good
morning good morning I have a couple of
questions in a comment to me during
World War two and also during the Korean
War the Canadians as well as the
Australians fort along with the United
States as well as their intelligence why
is it now that we rely mostly on Israel
and most of the other countries other
than these two countries have always
been an ally well I would I would I
think you're incorrect and the reliant
that we rely on Israel so much there is
a group that is made up of the United
States Canada Australia and
these are this is kind of a and Great
Britain and they are a kind of a semi
intelligence alliance where they do much
closer intelligence sharing than other
nations so I would say that we we do
share intelligence with those particular
nations more than other nations in the
world Sayreville New Jersey good morning
good morning how are you mr. Gertz uh
I'm very confused about something arafat
proves to be the terrorist he said he's
like the largest terrorist he and he
even gets a great reward for it the PLO
holds the record for the largest
hijacking for aircrafts in a single
operation 300 hostages held at one time
the most people shot at an airport the
largest ransom collected a five million
dollars pay by I believe it was was
close and loose um
handy pronounce his name sponsor says
something like that I'm sorry and also
they have the highest civilian targeting
forty civilian aircraft passenger fires
passengers ship xxx ambassador in
embassies diplomats missions plus
Tomlinson fuel disposition disposes
factories President Clinton meets with
him shakes his hand as if he was a great
person he's the greatest criminal the
greatest jurors the Pope meets with him
and says that they serve the st. Jesus
why don't they see where this man is
coming from well you know the whole
situation in the in the Middle East has
been numerous administration's and
governments have tried to solve the
problem I don't have the answer to it
myself you know if you read the
headlines today they're almost identical
as the headlines ten years ago this is
clearly one of the biggest problems in
the world trying to solve the
arab-israeli dispute and I just don't
have the answers to it Wyandotte
Michigan you're on the air would build
Gertz good morning yes good morning sir
it's a pleasure to speak with you very
much a pleasure I'm very pessimistic I
want to get your comments
the reason I'm Testament pessimistic is
because
as you see from the last election this
discount this country and our culture is
bitterly divided and a famous man once
that a house divided will not stand
also the insane and just crazy
immigration power lack of immigration
policy that we have where the borders
are virtually wide opened for illegal
immigration and then we have the crazy
quotas that we have as far as legal
immigration is concerned where you've
got anywhere the estimates I've heard
range from between both legal and
illegal immigration you have anywhere
between 700,000 and maybe as high as two
million people entering this country
every year how are we going to keep
track of all this and many of these
people are coming in here with the
express intent of killing Americans it
is it's a huge problem
obviously there's there's no ways easy
way to do it you know we are an open
society our country was built on
immigration so the question is how
secure do you want to be or how open you
want to be and that's a debate that's
going on right now I don't know the
answers to how you balance the two
clearly if we have terrorist groups that
are killing thousands of Americans
something needs to be fixed I think
there are technology solutions clearly
the Immigration and Naturalization
Service has has come under fire for its
problems they're hoping that this
Homeland Security Department will fix it
I think I agree with you I think it's a
it's an uphill battle next call for Bill
Gertz comes from Saratoga Springs New
York good morning good morning mr.
Gert's I have a question regarding the
the main thesis or conclusion of your
book I haven't read it yet I certainly
intend to are you saying a that due to
the inherent weakness of our
intelligence community and its structure
and the problems that that brings about
we were unable to detect the 9/11
disaster
or be get even given these inherent
problems with the intelligence community
and its gathering of information even so
we should have been able to detect it
which of which of those two is closest
to your thoughts I think that the a part
is is my argument that we our
intelligence community has eroded and I
trace the beginning point of that to the
period of 1975 when there were a series
of congressional hearings in the head in
the Senate headed by Senator Frank
church in the house headed by
representative Otis Pike which did
tremendous damage to America's
intelligence capability this was really
the first time the American people were
exposed to intelligence and they were
given an extremely negative picture the
going and assumption of many of these
Liberal Democrats was that intelligence
at best is criminal activity and at
worst a threat to the Constitution and
that bias began a whole generation of
government officials who went into
intelligence who went into the
government and they carried that bias
with them and they inflicted serious
damage most notably on our ability to
spy on the street level as I said
earlier the the failure of intelligence
in September 11th was a failure to find
out who these terrorists were and what
they were up to Bill Gertz do you have
any idea how many spies or intelligence
officers or overseas don't I'm told that
the community of the Directorate of
operations that is the people that are
trained in the arts of and craft of
espionage is somewhere in the range of
about 10,000 but it's it's hard to say
how many actual case officer that is
someone who is trained to be a spy and
to recruit agents are out there because
there is so much support personnel
there's so much technology involved in
by operations today so that it's hard
and of course the numbers are classified
but I would say a ballpark figure would
be in in the 10000 range Cleveland Ohio
good morning good morning I have a
perception of what the situation is that
I'd like you to comment on and just to
cite three major examples of what gave
me this perception is the attack on
Pearl Harbor led to major consequences
the attack by the Germans and the
Ardennes Forest would least led to major
consequences in the Battle of the Bulge
and the more recent 9/11 incident my
perception is that our failure is not in
our ability to collect intelligence
information our ability is - our failure
is in our ability to act effectively on
it and I'm wondering whether it is in
our political system in our culture that
creates this these failures and whether
this is it's possible to fix it okay
yeah you mentioned those those issues I
look at at least the first one Pearl
Harbor and it's it's interesting to note
that the CIA was formed on the
foundation that we need a central agency
that can collate information pieces of
information and prevent another Pearl
Harbor type attack so if that was the
reason for the CIA then clearly you
could compare 9/11 to a second Pearl
Harbor and it did not fulfill its its
fundamental function the Ardennes and
the Battle of the Bulge it's my
understanding that clearly the victory
in world war ii was a an electronic
intelligence success the ability to read
the german military communications led
to huge successes and I think that
perhaps by that date and I'm not certain
of my history on this
but we may not have had that ability at
that time whereas earlier in the war we
did have the ability to read the German
codes and as 9/11 came about again I
would go back to this notion that when
you have a terrorist group that
announces that it's going to kill
Americans and that they're actually
doing that that is your 100% warning
that you have a major problem and I just
don't feel like that we did enough to go
after al-qaeda
now obviously the CIA would differ with
that but clearly there wasn't enough
done because we had the signs and we
didn't do it you know Jim Woolsey who I
mentioned earlier the former CIA
director said one of the problems was
that during the 90s we were on kind of a
decade-long beach party the Cold War had
ended and clearly you know the motto of
the Clinton administration was not it's
the national security stupid their focus
was on the economy and that was to the
detriment of our national security and I
think that was really in if you
mentioned perceptions that was a key
problem Shreveport Louisiana good
morning hello
yes sir I've got two questions for the
mr. Girt concerning the our involvement
and overthrowing or taking out other
foreign leaders in the past in recent
history we've taken a big part in
sharper in the Marcus's in the
Philippines Batista and Cuba and seemed
like to me the things we got in return
were a little bit quite a bit worse than
what was there to begin with and what
makes us thank for a second that there's
something better over there to take over
Iraq than Adam okay well I would I would
say I wouldn't take the those those
early intelligence coos or us driven
changes of regime out of the context of
the Cold War I mean
was clearly the context the US was
fighting communism and that was the
underlying rationale for putting putting
regimes in place that were friendly to
the United States in the case of Iraq I
got to tell you that the political noise
recently has had and I've been in
Washington a long time and I cannot make
sense out of what is going on but I can
tell you and my guess is that what we're
witnessing is the external manifestation
of an internal policy debate on how to
get rid of Saddam Hussein I can tell you
that people in the military community
don't like the idea that the whole world
knows that we're planning to invade a
country I mean the very first thing that
the military people like is the element
of surprise and clearly you don't have
that when you're discussing how you're
going to overthrow a dictatorship in
Iraq and the last call for Bill Gertz
Morgantown West Virginia good morning
good morning I have a two-part question
I guess if I can keep my nerves together
I'm a little nervous my question is in
your book do you discuss anything about
the how the CIA and the FBI are
hamstrung by the Congress and the Senate
because I keep hearing every year that
the Congress and the Senate somebody
makes an announcement they're not going
to fund these two agencies any longer
until they report in now do they now I
don't understand why it goes through the
Congress the Senate but it seems to me
that since it does go through them
it's hamstringing them and it's probably
more of pya rather than not you know
doing a job I don't understand how they
control what the these two these two
organizations do these investigative
organizations
okay well the simple answer is please
read my book because I have a whole
chapter what I call destructive
oversight and I traced the roots back to
the the church in Pike committees where
oversight was
severely restricted intelligence and
then there was a period after that
beginning in the 80s sometime where
intelligence the pendulum swung in the
other direction and where instead of
having performance-based oversight that
is oversight that's geared towards
getting our money's worth out of
intelligence you had a kind of
cheerleading going on and I think that's
one of the problems we're facing today
there are very few voices in the
Congress that are really willing to
press the intelligence community senator
Shelby being one of the more outspoken
people he was he's the ranking member on
the Senate Intelligence Committee but
really there needs to be a look at
intelligence oversight and and what it's
supposed to do and you know I light
stories about how even some of the
simplest things like forcing the
intelligence community to standardize
its names were resisted and in many ways
the intelligence community has co-opted
the oversight committees many of its
staff members are former intelligence
members at former intelligence community
members and they carry with them their
institutional favoritism in a lot of
ways in some cases they are they are
putting heat on the intelligence
community and they do impose
restrictions so it's a mixed bag but
overall it hasn't really produced a
better intelligence community bill Gertz
is the author of this book it's
brand-new breakdown how America's
intelligence failures led to 9/11